Jason stark the great baseball rider for
the athletic senior baseball rider MLB
Network studio analyst kind enough to
join us good morning Jason how are you
I'm doing great I'm doing great but I
couldn't help but watch that press
conference with Bryce Harper and and
just go oh wow he's he's not flirting it
feels like he's holding hands with Mike
Trout like a my roller compared speech
can players be charged with tampering no
I know he didn't write a check but what
do you think about that possibility that
he did to Scott he did talk to Mike
Trout about this you know I don't know
when negotiations start or started with
trout to keep him there but it feels
like this is sort of an open love letter
to Mike Trout to say I took less this is
a team friendly deal I'm making room for
you oh I think you're reading it right I
actually wrote about this three months
ago that the Phillies had there are
copies on uniting these two guys they
know everything you would ever want to
know about Mike Trout and it was
favorite lunch spots in Millville they
can tell you exactly where his Eagles
season tickets are they know everything
about him and if by some miracle he ever
he ever gives them that opportunity to
sign as a free agent or trade for him
that is going to happen yeah but you saw
the way this owner pursued Bryce Harper
now imagine that's Mike Trout oh my god
but if you're the Angels in your arty
Moreno I'm guessing a 1213 year
400 million dollar deal could that get
it done and is Mike Trout happy in with
the Angels well I think he's very
comfortable there and I don't know
anybody who would tell you otherwise
and you know there's kind of a narrative
that you he loves Philadelphia I talked
to a friend of his for that story I
wrote and he said you know Mike doesn't
think himself as a Philadelphia guy he
thinks of himself as a Millville guy
and Nova New Jersey is not exactly South
Philly right so I don't think this is a
done deal that he's gonna force his way
out of there and wound up in
Philadelphia I really don't you know
somebody told me two weeks ago I was in
Arizona there is no way that already
been ran out allows Mike Trout to leave
and I honestly believe that I also think
it was one of the motivations for the
facilities to do what they did and this
might be the only opportunity they get
to sign a star of this magnitude talking
to Jason Stark the athletic senior
baseball writer and contributor to the
major league baseball network you also
look at that city that city that you
know so well the the romance period with
Philadelphia and Bryce Harper how long
does it last
of course I talked about Jason Werth
good friend owes Bryce Harper's and
played with him six years in Washington
and I said well what do you think the
over-under is on when Bryce first gets
booed and he said you really think on
his first day silly and Jason would said
you really think that's out of the realm
of possibility this is not gonna be the
bachelor you know it's not going to be
that kind of love fest it's going to be
very different there's gonna be jerseys
flying off the shelves and ticket sales
and love and all that's wonderful but
think of the ups and downs
Bryce has had in his career and when he
goes through those downs people who
notice I think that's safe to say
is dr. J the only significant athlete in
Philadelphia didn't get booed you know I
think Chase Utley is also in that group
now Jay tells the story you know he had
a grand slam in his birthday back in his
career
struck out in his second at-bat and
he says he got I don't like the odds of
race going through 13 years I'm not
getting booed zero yeah I was also
wondering this and I've asked some of
our baseball guests that if I look at
Aaron judge and what he's gonna be worth
to stay with the Yankees I don't he
doesn't strike me as a guy who's gonna
go in the open market Mookie Betts what
he's gonna mean to the Red Sox and what
Mike Trout is gonna mean to the Angels
if you were gonna handicap those three
trout's gonna get the most I'm guessing
but where does Judge and Mookie Betts
fit in here when they get this big
contract extension well looky has got
the age thing going for him so maybe
that gets in more years judges
further away so it might be a whole
different labor deal by the time that
one gets done who the heck knows but
it's not incredible how things have
changed in like two weeks
seriously Dan I had people in baseball
telling me this this month that no
player would ever get a 10-year contract
again so much for that yeah here's Manny
thirteen years for Bryce and I would
love to be proud Mookie judge of these
yeah I hate these ten-year deals and I
know that yet the Padres had to go to
ten or they wouldn't they won't get him
it's sort of like what the Angels did
you know when you know Artie is gonna go
all-in on Albert Pujols you know I had
to I have to give you a deal that you
can't turn down which deal is going to
be worse the phillies of the padres I
can't imagine that 13 years of Bryce
Harper with no opt-outs
it is going to end well I don't know
that many fields gonna end well here's
the one thing that I think for me is a
separator
you can you can talk about all the the
metrics that you want the key senses of
ability of Manny Machado compared to
price you can tell me all of that here's
one thing I know that Bryce Harper he
wants to go down in history as an
all-time great player I really feel like
he wants to be some kind of cross
between Mickey Mantle Barry Bonds and
LeBron you know and I took like oh I'll
invest in that guy every time because
you can't be great unless you truly
aspire to be great and embrace does that
it's gonna be really fascinating to
watch all this unfold it's good to check
in with you Jason glad you're doing well
and we appreciate your time as always a
pleasure
that's Jason stark the athletics senior
baseball writer for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]